hello again in the last video we were
looking at vector fields that only have
an X component basically meaning all of
the vectors point just purely to the
left or to the right with nothing up and
down going on and we landed at the idea
that that divergence of V you know when
you take the divergence of this vector
valued function it should definitely
have something to do with the partial
derivative of P that X component of the
output with respect to X and here I want
to do the opposite and say okay what if
we look at functions where that P that
first component is zero but then we have
some kind of positive Q component some
kind of positive or net maybe not
positive but some kind of non zero so
positive or negative Y component and
what this would mean instead of thinking
about vectors just left and right now
we're looking at vectors that are purely
up or down kind of up or down so kind of
doing the same thing we did last time if
we start thinking about cases where the
divergence of our function at a given
point should be positive and an example
of that you might be saying nothing is
happening at the point itself so Q
itself would be zero but then below it
things are kind of going away so they're
pointing down and above it things are
going up so in this case down here Q is
a little bit less than zero the Y
component of that vector is less than
zero and up here Q is greater than zero
so here we have the idea that as you're
going from the bottom up so you the Y
value of your input is increasing as
you're moving upwards in space the value
of Q this Y component of the output
should also be increasing because it
goes from negative to zero to positive
so now you're starting to get this idea
of partial Q with respect to Y you know
as we change that Y and move up in space
the value of Q should be positive so
positive divergence seems to correspond
to a positive value here and the
thinking is actually going to be almost
identical to what we did in the last
video with the X component because you
can think of another circumstance where
maybe you actually have a vector
attached to your point and something is
going on and there even is some
convergence towards it where you have
some fluid flow in towards the point but
it's just heavily outweighed by even
higher divergence even higher flow away
from your point above it and again you
have this idea of Q starts off small so
here's kind of
Hugh starts off small maybe it's kind of
like near zero and then here q is
something positive and then here it's
even more positive and sort of making up
notation here but I want the idea of
kind of small and then medium-sized and
then bigger and once again
the idea of partial derivative of Q with
respect to Y being greater than zero
seems to correspond to positive
divergence and if you want you can
sketch out many more circumstances and
think about you know what if the vector
started off pointing down what would
positive and negative and 0 divergence
all look like but the upshot of it all
pretty much for the same reasons I went
through in the last video is this
partial derivative with respect to Y
corresponds to the divergence and we
when we combine this with our
conclusions about the X component that
actually is all you need to know for the
divergence so just to write it all out
if we have a vector valued function of x
and y and it's got both of its
components you've got P as the X
component of the output that first
component of the output and Q and we're
looking at both of these at once the way
that we compute divergence the
definition of divergence of this vector
valued function is to say the divergence
of V as a function of x and y is
actually equal to the partial derivative
of P with respect to X plus the partial
derivative of Q with respect to Y and
that's it that is the formula for
divergence and hopefully by now this
isn't just kind of a formula that I'm
popping down for you but it's something
that makes intuitive sense when you see
this term this partial P with respect to
X you're thinking about oh yes yes
because if you have flow that's kind of
increasing as you move in the X
direction that's going to correspond
with movement away and this partial
derivative of Q with respect to Y term
hopefully your thinking is as you're
increasing the Y component of your
vector around your point that
corresponds with less flow in than there
is out so both of these correspond to
that that idea of divergence that we're
going for and if you just add them up
this gives you everything you need to
know
and one thing that's pretty neat and
maybe kind of surprising is that the way
we just came across this formula and
started to think about it was in the
simplified case where you have you know
just pure movement in the X direction or
pure movement in the Y direction but in
reality as we know vector fields can
look much more complicated and maybe you
have something where you know it's not
just in the X direction there's lots of
things going on and you need to account
for all of those and evidently just
looking at the change in the X component
with respect to X or the change in the Y
component of the output with respect to
the y component of the input gives you
all the information you need to know and
basically what's going on here is that
any fluid flow can just be broken down
into the X and y components where you're
just looking at each vector you know
what whatever vector you have it could
be broken down into its own x and y
components and if you want to think kind
of concretely about the fluid flow idea
maybe you'd say that for for your point
if you're looking at a point in space
you picture a very small box around it
and the reason you only need to think
about X components and Y components is
that you're only really looking at you
know what's going on on the left and
right side and then you can kind of
calculate what the divergence according
to fluid flowing in through those sides
is and then you just look at kind of
fluid flowing through the top or the
bottom and if you kind of shrink this
box down all you really care about is
those those two different directions and
anything else anything that's kind of a
diagonal into it is really just broken
down into what's the Y component there
what's the what you know how is it
contributing to movement up through that
bottom part of the box and then what's
the X component how's it contributing to
movement to that side part of the box
but anyway I mean the upshot here is
just that the formula for divergence
only involves these two components